Russia's foreign minister Sergey levrov
is meeting his Iranian counterpart Jose
Amir Abdullahi in Moscow the nuclear
deal between Iran and the West is likely
to be on the agenda that also expected
to discuss Syria Afghanistan Ukraine and
issues related to the Caspian Sea region
let's go to Moscow and speak to
journalist Yulia chapovalova and what
are Russians want from this meeting
yes
well actually the meeting is still
underway and we are waiting for the news
conference any moment and we'll be able
to hear from both ministers and from
their delegation members uh what's been
discussed and uh we know that the
delegations also discuss the Iranian
we're going to discuss the Iranian
nuclear program in terms of the joint
comprehensive plan of actions as well as
the State of Affairs in various
countries of the caucuses and Caspian
regions so the Russian Iranian
Corporation is growing of course and it
is quite obvious as both countries are
sanctioned by other states but believe
it or not if you get to the streets of
Russian cities and ask people who is a
friend of Russia nowadays the people
will answer you it is a run so many
things are going on on a daily basis
between the two countries here like
economy energy tourism Etc Russia has
always been tehran's allies supporting
it for years so nowadays the trade
turnover is growing and this is
something everyone here endorses so the
relations are developing and Russia's
relatively quickly finding a way to
overcome its isolation and other
problems caused by sanctions okay thank
you so much for the update that is Julia
shapovalova for us in Moscow we're going
to go to Ali Hashem who joins us from
Tehran and Iran and Russia seem to be
coordinating closely on many many
different issues what's the view from
Tehran
Russia is one of the main allies right
now let's say one of the countries that
Iran is having very good relations with
there's a lot of intersections with
respect to interests so maybe China
Russia these are the main uh partners of
of Iran mainly after the the sanctions
Iran is looking forward to get out to
overcome the isolation uh after the
sanctions and and now with Russia under
sanctions both countries are able to
cooperate in different ways if we go
back a few months ago president raisi
the president of Iran visited visited
Russia President Putin was here also a
few months ago so this is an ongoing
operation between the two countries and
on different layers economically uh
energy wise politically and also on the
Diplomatic side especially with Russia
are being part of the five plus one
previously and four plus one now the
partners of Iran and the nuclear deal so
to Iran it's really a priority to be in
full coordination with Russia and to go
maybe a step forward towards signing a
strategic Alliance or a partnership
which is something that Russian and
Iranian officials are expected to uh
talk about okay thank you so much that's
Ali Hashem for us in Tehran